all Street utilise des termes compliqués
pour vous faire croire qu'ils sont les
seuls à pouvoir faire ce qu'ils font au
mieux encore pour que vous leur foutiez
une paix royale donc je laisse Margot
Robbie dans un bain mousson vous
l'expliquer
bien en clair l'obligation que Ranieri a
mis au point a été méga profitable pour
les banques elles ont pris des milliards
et des milliards à coups de 2% de marge
sur chaque obligation vendue
puis ils se sont retrouvés à court de
près immo à mettre dedans après tout le
nombre de maisons comme de gens avec un
boulot pour les acheter et limiter
n'est-ce pas alors les banques ont
inclus des prêts de plus en plus risqués
dans leurs obligations merci
comme ça ils gardent la main sur la
machine à cache ok ah et puis au fait
c'est prêt hyper risqué ce sont les
subprimes dès lors qu'on vous dit
subprimes traduisez merde
notre ami Michael Berry il vient de
réaliser que ses obligations
hypothécaires supposées être à 65%
triple A sont en réalité un gros tas de
merde donc ce qu'il veut c'est shorter
les obligations autrement dit parier
contre elle
c'est rentré
alors foutez le camp
vous sentez c'est quoi ça quoi ce qui
sent comme ça
l'opportunité non le fric oh d'accord je
sens le fric ok Chris
ceci est votre obligation hypothécaire
classique d'accord les premiers montages
étaient simples c'était juste des
structures de milliers de prêts triple a
réuni garanti par le gouvernement les
plus récentes sont différentes elles
sont privées c'est un empilement de
différentes tranches
la plus haute la triple A est payée en
priorité la plus basse la baie en
dernier sera donc la première à faire
défaut maintenant si vous achetez des
baies ça peut payer plus mais elles sont
un peu risqué parfois ils font défaut
Chris
en cours de route certaines baies et
double B sont passés d'un peu risqué ah
merde de chien où est la corbeille juste
derrière vous je parle des plus bas
scores de crédit
pas de vérification de revenus
taux variable merde de chien
le taux de défaut déjà passé de 1 à 4%
les gars et s'il atteint les 8% et il le
fera
quantité de triple baudront plus rien
non plus et ça c'est trop près
c'est une opportunité ok vous vous dites
à 8 % le marché des vies c'est que nous
sommes déjà à 4% tout à fait on a à 8
c'est Armageddon oui tout à fait comment
se fait-il que personne n'en parle on
peut se fier à vos chiffres regardez le
c'est mon Kant votre quoi mon
quantitatif mon mathématicien
regardez-le
il y a rien qui vous choque regardez sa
tête
regardez ses yeux je vous fais un indice
il s'appelle Yang
il a gagné un concours national de maths
en Chine il parle même pas notre langue
oui fiez-vous à mes chiffres
en vrai je m'appelle Diane et je parle
très bien votre langue Jared dit souvent
ça parce qu'il trouve que ça me rend
plus authentique et j'ai fini second au
concours de maths en question vous nous
offrez donc l'occasion de shorter cette
pile de bâtonnets comment avec un bel
outil intitulé contrat de swap
une sorte d'assurance sur l'obligation
si elle baisse vous empêchez 10 fois
voir 20 fois la mise et elle a déjà
amorcé une baisse des fois 20 fois
jamais et personne remarque que dalle
personne remarque que dalle parce que
les banques sont trop occupées à rafler
des commissions à descentes sur ses
obligations attendez vous êtes une
banque vous bossez pour une banque je
suppose que vos marges sont bien grasses
vous occupez pas de mes marges par
ailleurs bien grâce en effet jolie
chemises ils font les mêmes pour hommes
mais vous êtes une banque non je bosse
pour une banque je pense pas comme une
banque petite banque grande banque
j'aime quand ça paye vous y êtes je vous
fais un dessin je me trouve devant une
maison en feu et je peux vous offrir une
assurance incendie comment ces
obligations peuvent être aussi pourries
que vous le dites ce serait pas légal
personne sait ce qu'elle contienne
personne sait ce qu'il y a dans ses
obligations j'en connais qui sont notés
à 65% triple A sachant pertinemment
qu'elles sont remplies à 95% de
subprimes merdique au score inférieur à
550 vous vous foutez de notre gueule
vous voulez vraiment triper quand le
marché estime une obligation risquée
pour lui on en fait quoi
devinez j'en sais rien dites-moi
d'accord vous croyez qu'on qu'on la
stocke dans nos positions non on la
mélange à d'autres mères difficiles à
écouler et on met le tout dans un CDO un
CDO
c'est quoi ça on prend un lot de BW
triple B resté invendus et on fait une
pile
une fois que la pile est assez haute la
structure paraît subitement diversifiée
et les clébards des agences de notation
lui accorde un 92 ou 93% de triple A
sans chercher plus loin
une seconde redis ça
structure de créances hypothécaire c'est
important que ce soit clair parce que
c'est ce qui a fait d'une crise de
l'immobilier une cata économique
nationale
je laisse le célèbre chef Anthony
Bourdin vous l'expliquer
[Rires]
bon je suis un chef un dimanche
après-midi je fais la carte d'un grand
restaurant j'ai commandé mes poissons
vendredi ce sont les obligations que
Michael Berry a short et j'ai plusieurs
invendus au final pourquoi je sais pas
peut-être qu'on a annoncé que le flétan
à l'intelligence d'un dauphin enfin du
coup je fais quoi ces poissons qui
restent qui correspondent au triple B de
l'obligation j'en assume la perte et je
les jette
jamais en bon chef rusé sans scrupule
que je suis quel que soit le niveau
merdique des obligations invendus je les
mets dans un ragoût de poisson
c'est plus de la vendue c'est une
nouveauté et le plus beau c'est qu'il
mange du flétan qui a trois jours c'est
ça un CDO
le premier 2 secondes 2 secondes donc
les MBS sont des merdes de chiens les
CDO démerdes de chats pleines de merde
de chien
oui en substance d'accord les
institutions considèrent les CDO si
fiables que des bons du Trésor ils vont
valoir 0 non non c'est pas crédible il y
a eu 500 milliards d'obligations et
coulaient rien que l'an dernier les
agences de notation les banques l'état
carrément vous dites qui sont tous
endormis au volant
mon département continue d'investir
il m'appelle chicken Little
m'appelle bubulle
A0 b0w
et voilà ce qui arrive c'est quoi ce qui
arrive
c'est notre marché immobilier
merci tu assures toi tu fermes ta gueule
ok voilà comment marche un CDO
synthétique mettons que je mise 10
millions sur une main au black tac 10
millions parce que dans notre cas cette
main représente une obligation
hypothécaire
ok Selena une très bonne main elle
reçoit 18 c'est pour le Coupier une
excellente main pour Selena cette bonne
augure ses chances de gagner cette main
sont de 87%. donc mes chances sont
excellentes j'ai la main heureuse ce
soir tout le monde autour de moi a envie
d'en profiter pas de danger que je perde
voilà ça c'est l'erreur classique au
basket on appelle ça l'illusion des
séries vous marquez plusieurs paniers de
suite au cours du jeu le public est sûr
que vous marquerez le suivant les gens
pensent que ce qui se produit maintenant
continuera de se produire dans le futur
pendant le boom de l'immobilier les
marchés montaient montaient et les gens
pensaient qu'il n'allaient jamais
redescendre donc les gens qui me
regardent certains que je vais gagner
vont parier en parallèle ce qui donne le
premier CD au synthétique j'adore Selena
Gomez je parie 50 millions qu'elle gagne
et je vous donne du trois contre un
trois contrats
ok je relève le pari maintenant
quelqu'un d'autre va vouloir à son tour
parier sur l'issue du premier Paris 50
millions qu'elle gagne au CD au
synthétique numéro 2 eh je parie 200
briques que la dame à lunettes gagne son
pari c'est bien parti pour
qu'elle
gogo et voilà comment on transforme un
investissement initial de 10 millions en
plusieurs milliards de dollars